the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay guys welcome back as you can see
we're not using the screen today this is
gonna be one of those fill the board
lectures but I am going to work you
through every single step we're going to
go through the Q equation and derive its
most general form together which for the
rest of this class will be using
simplified or reduced forms to explain a
lot of the ion or electron nuclear
interactions as well as things like
neutron scattering and all sorts of
other stuff we'll do one example for any
of you that have looked at neutrons
slowing down before how much energy can
a neutron lose when it hits something
we'll be answering that question today
in a generally mathematical form and
then a few lectures later we'll be going
over some of the more intuitive aspects
to help explain it for everybody so I'm
gonna show you the same situation that
we've been describing sort of
intuitively so far but we're going to
hit it mathematically today let's say
there's a small nucleus one that's
firing at a large nucleus two and
afterwards a different small nucleus
three and a different large nucleus four
come flying out and so we're going to
keep this as general as possible so
let's say if we draw angles from their
original paths particle three went off
at angle theta and particle four went
off at angle fee so hopefully those are
differentiable enough and if we were to
write the overall Q equation showing the
diff the balance between mass and energy
here we would simply have the mass 1 C
squared plus kinetic energy of 1 so in
this case we're just saying that the
mass and the kinetic energy of all
particles on the left side and the right
side has to be conserved so let's add
mass to C squared plus t2 has to equal
mass 3 C squared plus t3 plus mass 4 C
squared plus t4 we're just four symbols
M refers to a mass t refers to a kinetic
energy
and so this conservation of total mass
or total energies got to be conserved
and we'll use it again because again we
can describe the queue or the energy
consumed or released by the reaction as
either the change in masses or the
change in energies so in this case we
can write that Q let's just group all of
the SI Squared's together for easier
writing if we take the initial masses -
the final masses then we get a picture
of how much mass was converted to energy
therefore how much energy is available
for the reaction or Q to turn it into
kinetic energy so in this case we can
put the kinetic energy of the final
products minus the kinetic energies and
keep with one of the initial products
and so we'll use this a little later on
one simplification that we'll make now
is we'll assume that if we're firing
particles at anything that anything
starts off at rest so we can start by
saying there's no T - that's just a
simplification that will make right now
and so then the question is what
quantities of this situation are we
likely to know which ones are we not
likely to know and which ones are left
to relate together so let's just go
through one by one would we typically
know the mass of the initial particle
coming in we probably know what we're
shooting at stuff
right so we've know m1 what about t1 the
initial kinetic energy sure let's say we
have a reactor whose energy we know or
an accelerator or something that we're
controlling the energy like in problem
set one we probably know that we
probably know what things were firing at
and we would probably know what the
masses of the final products are because
you guys have been doing nuclear
reaction analysis and calculating
binding energies and everything for the
last couple of weeks but we might not
know the kinetic energies of what's
coming out let's
we didn't actually even know the masses
yet we have to figure out a way to get
both the kinetic energies and what about
these angles here this is the new
variable that we're introducing is the
kinetic energy of particles three and
four is going to depend on what angles
they fire off at let me give you a
limiting case let's say theta was zero
what would that mean physically what
would be happening to particles one two
three and four if theta and fie were
zero if they kept on moving in the exact
same path yeah we don't know well let's
see if yeah if it was a fusion event
let's say there was one here and one
standing still then the whole center of
mass of the system would have to move
that way so one example could be a
fusion event a second example could be
absolutely nothing it's perfectly valid
to say if let's say particle one
scatters off particle two at an angle of
zero degrees that's what's known as
forward scattering which is to say that
theta equals zero so this is another
quantity that we might not know we might
not know what theta and phiy are and the
problem here is we've got like three or
four unknowns and only one equation to
relate them
so what other question when you say an
inelastic collision would be one and
since we haven't gone through what
inelastic means that would mean some
sort of collision where let's see how
would I explain this I'd say an
inelastic collision would be like if
particles 1 & 2 were to fuse like a
capture event for example or a capture
and then a readmission let's say of a
neutron yeah if it was readmitted in the
forward direction then that could be an
elastic scattering event but still in
the same direction or an elastic scatter
at an angle of theta equals zero could
be like there wasn't any scattering at
all because really in the end it can
matter
let's say if you have a neutron firing
at a nucleus depends on what angle it
bounces off of in like the billiard ball
sense if it bounces off at an angle of
zero that means it missed we would
consider that theta equals zero but the
point here is that we now have more
quantities unknown than we have
equations to define them so how else can
we start relating some of these
quantities what else can we conserve
since we've already got mass and energy
what's that third quantity I always yell
out momentum right so let's start
writing some of the momentum
conservation equations so we can try and
nail these things down
so let's I'm going to write each step
one at a time we'll start by conserving
momentum that's what we'll do right here
and we can write the X and the y
equation separately so what's the
momentum of particle one how do we
express that yep so it would be like m1
v1 so we'll have a little box right here
from momentum we could say mass times
velocity or how do we express that in
terms of variables that we have here
like we did last week what about in
terms of kinetic energies well another
way of writing mass times velocity would
be root to MT because in this case we
would have root two let's see root two
times m1 times one-half m1 v1 squared
the twos here cancel the let's see I
have m1 squared you have a V squared and
the square root of M squared V squared
is just MV so this is an equivalent way
of writing the momentum in the variables
that we're working in already and so
since that doesn't introduce another
variable like velocity which we do know
but it's kind of confusing to add more
symbols let's keep as few as possible
so what's the X momentum of particle one
just what I've got up there to em 1 T 1
what's the X momentum in this frame of
particle 2 0 it's not we're assuming
that it's at rest and now what's the X
momentum of particle 3 I heard a couple
of things can say him louder it's ready
- yep root 2m 3 T 3 but in this case if
we're defining let's say our x-axis here
it also matters what this angle is so
you've got to multiply by cosine theta
in this case and that's the X momentum
of particle 3 and we've also got to
account for particle 4 so we'll say add
to em 44 cosine fee now let's do the
same thing for the Y momentum what's the
Y momentum of particles 1 & 2 0 there's
not moving in the Y direction to start
and how about particle 3 I hear whispers
but nothing vocalized yep same thing but
root 2 M 3 T 3 sine theta and M 4 I
almost wrote the wrong sign there has
got to be a minus if the momentum of the
initial particle system in the Y
Direction is zero so must the final
momentum in the Y direction so these two
momentum has to be equal and opposite
and that's time sine fee so now we
actually have sets of equations that
relate all of our unknown quantities we
have the mass conservation equation we
have the Q equation we have the X
momentum and we have the Y momentum and
from this point on it's a matter of
algebra to express some of these
the DS in terms of some of the others so
let's get started with that because we
angles are kind of messy and theta will
use theta should uniquely define fee
let's try and get things in terms of
just one angle so I'm going to start by
separating the Thetas and the fees on
either side of the equal sign so that
hopefully later on we can eliminate one
in a system of equations so all I'm
going to do is I'm going to subtract or
add the theta terms to the other side of
the equation so let's say it will
separate angles so we'll have root 2 m 1
t 1 and minus root 2 M 3 t 3 cosine
theta I'll be depending on you guys to
check for sign errors here because those
will be messy I do have notes in case
but I'm hoping I won't have to look at
them and all we have left on this side
is root 2 m 4 T 4 cosine fee so that's
the X momentum equation let's do the
same thing with the Y momentum equation
so all we'll do is take the theta term
and stick it to the left of the equal
sign so that would give us minus root 2
M 3 t 3 sine theta equals minus root 2 M
44 sine fee right away we can see that
the minus signs can cancel out just for
simplicity and what else is common to
these that we can get rid of yep
everything here has a square root of 2
so we'll just get rid of all of the
square root of twos to simplify as much
as possible and now we look a little
stuck but now's the time to remember
those trigonometric identities back from
high school that I don't think does
anyone use these since in 1801 or 1802
anyone used a trig identity
a little bit okay um I would hope so but
I don't know what other people are
teaching nowadays at least this way I'll
make sure you remember the high school
stuff we're going to rely on the fact
that we already got a cosine and a sine
we have a set of simultaneous equations
if we can add them together and destroy
the angles somehow that will make things
a lot easier so for the Thetas we have a
cosine a sine and an unangan the term
that looks kind of messy here we have a
cosine and a sine anyone have any idea
where we could go next to destroy one of
these angles anyone remember any handy
cosine or sine trig identities exactly
so we can rely on the fact that if we
can square both sides of both equations
and add them up we would have a cosine
squared of fee plus a sine squared of
fee which also equals one so we can
destroy this fee angle and make things a
lot simpler so we'll start by squaring
both sides let's start with the X
momentum equation so if we have let's
see root M 1 T 1 this so we're gonna
take that stuff squared and that square
it's not too hard neither are those so
we'll have root M 1 t 1 squared which
just gives us M 1 t 1 minus root M 1 T 1
times root M t-33 cosine theta let's
just lump those terms together as root M
1 and 3 t 1 t 3 cosine theta also anyone
raise your hand or let me know if I'm
going too fast I'm trying to hit every
single step but in case I skip one
please slow me down that's what classes
for
okay and then we've got another one
let's just stick a two in front of there
and Plus that term squared so we'll have
em 3t three let's see
yeah looks like cosine squared of theta
yep equals this one's easier m44 cosine
squared of fee okay now we'll do the
same thing for the Y momentum equation
much easier because there's no addition
anywhere and we have m3t three sine
squared theta here equals M for T for
sine squared feet so this is quite nice
now if we add these equations together
we get rid of all of the cosine and sine
squared terms so let's add them up let's
see we'll add the two equations
and equations and let's try and group
all the terms together so we have M 1 T
1 minus 2 root M 1 M 3 it's getting hard
to write over the lip of the chalkboard
here cosine theta and we have M 3 t 3
cosine squared theta plus M 3 t 3 sine
theta so we're sine squared theta equals
M 44 cosine squared theta plus sine
squared theta or fee I'm sorry cosine
squared fee plus sine squared fee okay
hopefully that's as low as I'll have to
write and like we saw before cosine
squared plus sine squared equals 1 so
that goes away that goes away and let's
keep going over on this side of the
board I told you this would be a fill
the board day let's see if we actually
get all 6 instead of just the 4 visible
but I think we'll finish this derivation
in 4 boards so let's write what we've
got left see your remaining so we have M
1 T 1 minus 2 root M 1 M 3 so much
easier to write standing up cosine theta
equals M 44 quite a bit simpler did I
miss a term ah thank you right you're
right and we had a plus M 3 T 3 yep that
would be important thank you
equals M 44 so we now have a relation
between the math
the energies and one angle which is
getting a lot better we still have one
more variable than we can deal with so
let's say if we're let's see which of
these variables do you think we can
eliminate using any of the equations you
see let's go with on that top board over
there well what other quantities are we
likely to know about this nuclear
reaction let's bring this back down are
we likely to know the Q value yeah
probably because like you guys have been
doing on problem sets 1 & 2 if you know
let's say the binding energies or the
masses or the excess masses or the
kinetic energies of all your products
any combination of those can get you the
Q value of that reaction and if you just
look up those reactions like let's say
radioactive decay reactions on the table
of nuclides it just gives you the Q
value so chances are we can express some
of these kinetic energies in terms of Q
and all we've got left is t1 t3 and t4
so which of these are we most likely to
be able to know or measure t1 we
probably fixed it by cranking up our
particle accelerator to a certain energy
t3 or t4 what do you guys think let's
say we had a very small nucleus firing
at a very big one which one do you think
would be more likely to escape this
system and get detected by us standing a
couple feet away with a detector yep
probably t3 the smaller particle we've
just arbitrarily chosen that but for
intuitive sake let's say yeah why don't
we try and get t4 in terms of Q t1 and
t3 that's not too hard since it's
addition so our next step will be
substitute
and we'll say that Q equals I'm just
gonna copy it up from there
t3 plus t4 minus t1 so we can isolate t4
say t4 equals Q plus T 1 minus T 3 and
continue substituting usually don't like
to have my back to the class this much
but when you're writing this much it can
be a little hard so let's stick this t4
in right here and rewrite the equation
as we've got it
M 1 t1 minus 2 root m1 m3 t1 t3 cosine
theta plus M 3 T 3 equals M 4 times Q
plus t1 minus t3 I anticipate us needing
to see this side of the board soon also
apologize for the amount of time it
takes to write these things there's
another strategy one can use at the
board which is defining intermediate
symbols and here's why I'm not doing
that when I was a freshman
back in whoa 2001 who here was born
after 2001 nobody ok thank God don't
feel so old we had I was in 1802 3 which
was math with applications which was
better known as math with extra theory
and in one class not only did we fill
nine boards but we ran out of English
letters symbols and we ran out of Greek
letter symbols and we moved on to Hebrew
because they were like distinct enough
from English and Greek and being I think
the only Hebrew speaker in the class I
was the only one that could follow the
symbols but I couldn't follow the math
anymore so I am NOT going to define
intermediate symbols for this and just
keep it understandable even if it takes
longer to write ok
so let's start off by dividing by M for
our goal now is to try to isolate Q
because this is something that we would
know or measure and it will relate all
of the other quantities only one of
which we won't really know yet so let's
divide everything by m4 so we have t1
over or sorry t1 times M 1 over m 4
minus 2 over m 4 times root of all that
stuff plus T 3 times M 3 over m 4 equals
Q plus T 1 minus T 3 and we've almost
isolated Q I'll call this step just add
and subtract and I'm going to group the
terms together so let's for example
group all the t ones together and group
all the t threes together so if I
subtract T 1 I get T 1 times M 1 over m
4 minus 1 minus 2 over m 4 root M 1 M 3
T 1 T 3 cosine theta plus and if I add T
3 then I would get M 3 over m 4 plus 1
equals Q so this is a good place to stop
turn around and see you guys and now ask
you which of the remaining quantities do
we probably not know so let's just go
through them one by one just to remind
ourselves are we likely to know what T 1
is probably how about the masses M 1 and
M 4 if we know what particles are
reacting we can just look those up or
measure them or whatever
we know M 4 we know our masses we know T
1
what about T 3 we don't necessarily know
yet so T 3 is a question mark how about
cosine theta or theta
we haven't said yet and t3 we don't know
and the masses we know and the queue we
know so finally to solve for well we
only have two variables left t3 and
theta so this here this is actually
called the queue equation in its most
complete form describes the relationship
between the kinetic energy of the
outgoing particle and the angle at which
it comes off how do we solve this how do
we get one in terms of the other anyone
recognize what kind of equation we have
here it's a little obscure oh it's not
obscure but it's a little bit hiding but
it should be a very familiar one think
back to high school again yes
let's see certainly there's probably
some trig involved in here in terms of
yeah if you know the cosine then you
know let's say the X or the Y component
of the momentum but there's something
simpler something that doesn't require
trigonometry yep it is it's a quadratic
hoop so who saw that it's actually a
quadratic equation where the variable is
the square root of t3 that's the trick
here is you have something without t3
you have something with square root T 3
and you have something with t3 better
known as root t 3 squared and there so
this is actually a quadratic equation
despite the fact that it may not have
looked that way in the first place there
we go so now someone who remembers from
high school tell me what are the roots
of a quadratic equation let's say if we
have the form y equals ax squared plus
BX plus C what does X equal just call it
out yep yep
over to a and in this case a is that
stuff B is that stuff without the t3 and
C is that stuff because we have like 15
minutes before I want to open it up to
questions and I don't think we have to
repeat the quadratic formula stuff I
will skip ahead skip ahead this is when
I'd normally say it's an exercise to the
reader but no it's not the phrase I like
to use it's boring and I can just tell
you guys what it ends up as is it ends
up with root T 3 equals and this is the
one time I am going to define new
symbols because it's just easier to
parse ends up being we'll call it s plus
or minus root a squared plus T or s
let's see if I can remember this without
looking it up now I have to look at my
notes I don't want to get it wrong and
have you all write it down incorrectly
because of me there we go the remaining
stuff in the square root B 1 cosine
theta over m 3 plus M 4 and T equals M 4
Q is it a - it is a + / M 3 plus M 4 so
these are the roots of this equation
this is how you can actually relate the
kinetic energy of the outgoing particle
directly to the angle so I want to let
that sink in just for a minute
stop here and check to see if there's
any questions on the derivation before
we start to use it to do something a
little more concrete yep
II oh I'm sorry that's a T thank you
kinetic energy again we should be
consistent with symbols and I think I
don't see any other hanging EES good
thank you so any other questions on the
derivation as we've done it we managed
to do it in less than four boards there
we go okay since I don't see any
questions let's get into a couple of the
implications of this so let's now look
at what defines an exothermic reaction
where we say if Q is greater than zero
which is to say that some of the mass
becomes kinetic energy if an exothermic
reaction is energetically possible then
what is the minimum t1 ah that's why I
brought it
what's the minimum t1 up here to make
that exothermic reaction happen we'll
put a condition on t1 so if the reaction
is exothermic which means it'll happen
spontaneously how much extra kinetic
energy do you have to give to the system
to make the reaction happen let's think
of it in the chemical sense if you have
an exothermic chemical reaction is it
spontaneous or is it not it is
spontaneous same thing in the nuclear
world if you have an exothermic nuclear
reaction do you need any kinetic energy
to start with to make it happen no okay
there we go so that's kind of the
analogy so t1 has to be greater than or
equal to zero it's pretty much not a
condition right it happens all the time
so if we were to say t1 were to equal
zero let me get my crossing out color
again if t1 were to equal zero then s
could equal 0 and t10 here and then you
just get that's an S
t equals m 4q over M 3 plus M 4 and this
just kind of gives you a relation
between the relative kinetic energies of
the two particles another way of writing
this relation would just be that III
plus e 4 has to be greater than or equal
to e 1 all this mmm thank you cuz ease
will be used in a different point of
this class so we'll stick with T for
kinetic energy thank you
so although that's how all that this
condition says is that if mass has been
converted to energy then that kinetic
energy at the end has to be greater than
at the beginning and that's all it is so
it makes this equation quite a lot
easier to solve for an exothermic
reaction you can also start to look to
say well what happens as we vary this
angle theta what does the kinetic energy
do let's take the case of an endothermic
reaction now we are running out of space
for an endothermic reaction where Q is
less than 0 you would for you would have
to have t1 to be greater than 0
otherwise the reaction can't occur so
you have to impart additional energy
into the system to get it going and it
also means that not every angle of a
mission is possible you might wonder why
do we care about the angle because the
reaction still happens anyway well it
doesn't happen at every angle and
reactions have different probabilities
of occurring depending on the angle at
which the things come out so you could
see here that as you vary t1 and as you
vary cosine theta you still have to make
sure that this quantity on the inside
here so s squared plus T always has to
be greater equal to greater than or
equal to 0 or else the roots of the
our imaginary and you don't have a
solution so it's kind of nice that this
came out quadratic because it lets you
take some of the knowledge you already
know and now apply it to say when or
when our nuclear reactions not or are
they allowed let me rephrase that when
our nuclear reactions allowed or not
allowed you can now tell depending on
the angle of emission and the incoming
energy and the masses which are all
things that you would tend to know so as
everyone clear on the implications here
if not let me know because that's what
this class is for yes so for exothermic
reactions where Q is greater than zero
all that says from our initial part of
the Q equation if Q is greater than zero
then we have this thing right here where
the final kinetic energies have to be
larger than the initial one which is to
say that some mass has turned into extra
kinetic energy and the solution to these
is pretty easy because you don't need
any kinetic energy to make an exothermic
reaction happen so you can just set t1
equal to zero which makes s equal to
zero because there's a all multiplied
here and then it simplifies lowercase T
as just a ratio of those masses times
the Q equation which will tell you
pretty much how much kinetic energy is
going to be sent off to particle three
right here yeah up there particle three
because then we have this condition if
root t3 equals s plus square root of s
squared plus T and we've decided that s
equals zero that just means that t3
equals lower case T which equals that so
then you uniquely define the kinetic
energy for an exothermic reaction as
long as you have no incoming kinetic
energy for the case of an endothermic
reaction first of all we know that the
incoming kinetic energy has to be
greater than zero it's like the it's
like the excess
you need to get a chemical reaction
going does anyone here ever played with
let's that's the one a striking one here
well has anyone ever led anything on no
that's yeah of course you have and
that's not a good explanation hmm what's
a good striking endothermic chemical
reaction anyone think of one yeah it's a
hydrogen generator I think that happened
yeah that's more like an explosion
that's like the intuitive definition of
exothermic yeah actually there's a fun
one you can do - is this great that it's
on video you do that plus put minging
these dioxide and hydrogen peroxide and
you have an oxygen generator and then
you have the purest beyond glacially
pure spring water you just mix H and O
directly just don't get near it because
it tends to be pretty loud we do this
for our RTC or reactor technology course
where I've got to teach a bunch of CEOs
enough basic high school chemistry so
they can understand reactor water
chemistry and the way I make sure that
I'm paying that they're paying attention
is with a tremendous explosion so folks
come here pay about 25 grand apiece for
me to fire water powered bottle rockets
out of them it's a pretty sweet job so
if you guys are interested in academia
you know these these things happen in
life it's pretty cool yeah all right so
I can't think of any endothermic
chemical reactions off the top of my
head I'll have to keep it general and
abstract and say if you have an
endothermic reaction you have to add
energy in the form of heat to get the
reaction going in an endothermic nuclear
reaction heating up the material does
not impart very much kinetic energy you
might raise it from a fraction of
electron volt to maybe a couple of
electron volts if things are so hot that
they're glowing in the ultraviolet that
doesn't cut it for nuclear so you have
to impart kinetic energy to the incoming
particle such that the kinetic energy
plus the rest masses is enough to create
the rest masses of the final particles
that's the general explanation I'd give
so I forget who had asked the question
but does that help explain it a bit
cool okay I'll take five minutes and
let's do a severely reduced case of this
the case of elastic neutron scattering
is kind of a flash forward to what we'll
be doing in the next month or so does
everyone have what's behind this board
here I know that was like three boards
ago so I hope so so let's take the case
of elastic neutron scattering remember I
told you that after we developed this
highly general solution to the QED
equation everything else that we're
gonna study is just a reduction of that
and this is about as reduced as it gets
so inelastic neutron scattering we can
say that m1 well what's the mass of a
neutron in AMU and let's forgive our six
decimal points precision for now what's
it about one so we can say that m1
equals one and in the case of elastic
scattering the particles bounce into
each other and leave with their original
identities so that also equals m3 if
we're shooting neutrons and an arbitrary
nucleus what's m2 yep just a the mass
number same as m4 now we don't have m2
in this equation whatever but the point
is yeah we're gonna use these two we're
gonna use these two so let's substitute
that in oh and one last other thing I
mentioned what is the Q value for
elastic scattering it write 0 because
the Q value is the difference in the
rest masses of the ingoing and outgoing
particles if the ingoing and outgoing
particles are the same m 1 equals M 3 M
2 equals M 4 that sum equals 0 therefore
Q equals 0 so let's use these three
things right here and rewrite the
general Q equation
in those terms which board is it on
right there so let's copy that down so
let's say we have T one times M 1 is 1
over M 4 is a minus 1 minus 2 over m 4
is a this is where it gets nice and easy
M 1 and M 3 are just 1 so 1 times 1
times T 1 we don't know what that is yet
so let's call it the TN T of the neutron
coming in how about this we'll call it t
in and T out for ease of understanding
cosine theta and what do we have left
Plus T out and let's make T 1 into an in
right there x + 3 / M 4 + 3 was one M 4
is a plus 1 equals Q equals 0 this is
quite a simpler equation to solve
so let's group this all together there's
a couple of tricks that I'm going to
apply right now to make sure that
everything has a in the denominator to
make stuff easier we can call one a of
Oreille here we can call one a over a
there then lets us combine our
denominators and stick the sign right
there that becomes an a same thing here
I'll just connect the dashes and stick
the minus sign there leaving an a right
there now we can just multiply
everything by a both sides of the
equation so the A's go away there we
have a much simpler equation 0 equals T
in of let's see
that's one minus a over one okay we'll
just call it one minus a minus two root
T in T out cosine theta plus T out a
plus one and okay it's ten minutes of or
it's five minutes of five minutes of so
I'm gonna stop this right here at a
fairly simple equation we'll pick it up
on Thursday and I want to open the last
five minutes to any questions you guys
may have since that request came in on
the anonymous rant form which hopefully
you all know now exists yep
so let's let's look at elastic
scattering as an example so inelastic
scattering two particles bounce off each
other like billiard balls in forward
elastic scattering the neutron after
interacting somehow with particle two
keeps moving forward unscathed so in the
last excatly sense forward scattering is
also known as missing you can have other
reactions let's say we have a particle
at rest another particle slams into it
and the center of the whole center of
mass moves together I don't know if
you'd call that forward scattering as
much as let's say capture or fusion or
something but in this case scattering
means that two particles go in two
particles leave whether it's elastically
which means with no transfer of energy
interests mass or inelastically or let's
say a neutron is absorbed and then re
emitted from a different energy level
and that's something we'll get into in
like a month so you can have forward
elastic or inelastic scattering in this
case I'm talking about elastic
scattering which is the simple case of
like the billiard balls miss each other
it's just technically a case that can be
treated by this because all you have to
do is plug in theta equals zero and you
have the case for how much how much
energy do you think the neutron would
lose if it misses particle two it
wouldn't lose any energy right it would
have the same energy so that's the case
for forward scattering a neutron when it
interacts somehow with another particle
can lose as little as none of its energy
if it misses no one said it had to lose
any energy and by solving this equation
here which we'll do on Thursday we'll
see what the maximum amount of energy
that Neutron can lose is which is the
basis for neutron slowing down or
moderation in reactors yeah
T&T out are not always equal but in the
case of forward elastic scattering they
would be because the neutron comes in
with energy T in and it leaves with
energy T in for any other case in which
the neutron comes off of particle two at
a different angle it will have bounced
off a particle two moving particle two
at some other angle fee and giving it
some of its energy elastically the total
amount of that kinetic energy will be
conserved so let's say what would we
call it what is it yeah so T three T one
would have to be the same as T 3 and T 4
together for this Q equation where Q
equals zero to be satisfied so that what
you said can happen but it's only the
case for forward scattering any other
questions yeah
so we the question was at an exothermic
reaction why did we say t1 equals zero
it's not always the case but it provides
the simplest case for us to analyze so
an exothermic reaction can happen when
t1 equals zero it can also happen when
t1 is greater than zero so we're not
putting any restrictions on that but in
the case that t1 equals 0 s is destroyed
and the comment the harder part of t is
destroyed making the solution to this
equation very simple and intuitive which
is to say that if you just have two
particles that are kind of at rest and
they just merge and fire off to
different pieces in opposite directions
their energies are proportional to the
ratio of their single mass to the total
mass so that's like a center of mass
problem you'll notice also I'm not using
center of mass coordinates center of
mass court here has used those in 801 or
802 and who here enjoyed the experience
oh wow
no hands whatsoever so center of mass
coordinates and laboratory coordinates
are different ways of expressing the
same thing usually you can write simpler
equations and center of mass coordinates
but for most people and I'm gonna go
with all of you since none of you raised
your hand it's not that intuitive that's
the same way for me so that's why I've
made a decision to show things in
laboratory coordinates so you have a
fixed frame of reference and not a
moving frame of reference of the center
of mass of the two particles but the
center of mass idea does kind of make
sense here if you have two particles
that are almost touching and then they
touch and they break into pieces and fly
off the total amount of momentum of that
center of mass was zero and it has to
remain zero and so each of these
particles will take a differing ratio of
their masses away we already looked at
this for the case of alpha decay where
if you have a one nucleus just sitting
here let's say there was no t1 there was
just some unstable t2 that was about to
explode and then it did remember how we
talked about how the Q value of an alpha
reaction is not the same energy that you
see the alpha decay ax
same thing right here so this Q equation
describes that same
situation notice there's no hint of m1
there was really no m1 in the end we
don't care what the initial mass of the
particle that made alpha decay is all we
care about is what are the mass ratios
and energy ratios of the alpha particle
and its recoil nucleus so it all does
tie together that's the neat thing is
this universal Q equation can be used to
describe like almost everything we're
going to talk about so this is as
complex as it gets and from now on we'll
be looking at simpler reductions and
specific cases of each one so it's v of
I would actually make sure to get you to
your next class on time and I'll see you
guys on Thursday